cómo se puede saber si alguien es latino
es por su forma de bailar o por la
música que escucha es por su aspecto o
por el idioma que habla
quizás sea por la comida que comen o por
su pasión por el fútbol
reunimos a siete latinos soy latina yo
soy latina yo soy latina yo soy latino
latino
[Música]
obviamente solo por mí caravana pensar
es latina no no lo creo
hola chicos hola chicos
chicas
vivo en Costa Rica y la verdad es que
estoy muy emocionada porque siento que
nunca tenemos representación todo el
mundo conoce a Argentina Brasil y demás
pero dicen Costa Rica de Puerto Rico y
no son países diferentes que también la
representación es importante soy mitad
puertorriqueña mitad mexicana pero fue
creada por mi mamá sí que me
relacionemos con la cultura de Puerto
Rico
no pero siguen siendo latinos al hablar
en inglés todos asumen que soy negro y
nadie piensa lo contrario es gracioso
porque cuando llegue aquí mi novia dijo
que eres la persona más oscura estoy
seguro de que tenía razón así que
tenía curiosidad por ver si las personas
pensaban si era Latina o no porque
siento que a veces no doy esa sensación
alguien me dijo que era ciática
muy bien los diablos la primera ronda
fue bastante agitada
voy a votar por Miguel Miguel Miguel
creo que él no parece muy mexicano
Miguel es demasiado obvio el que tiene
que salir primero no me compro Miguel
desconfío de Tomás apareció con una
camisa de Argentina podría ser solo un
fanático Ángela ella hacía preguntas
nosotros respondíamos y luego ella se va
a saber lo que decíamos así es más fácil
de saber contamos los votos de la
primera ronda
hermano lo Julia perdona eliminada de
esta ronda es
Miguel
dios mío Miguel
tenía muchas ganas de compartir mi
cultura y hablar sobre diferentes
aspectos y me acaban de eliminar
río la del pajarito volando en Argentina
como es un país bastante católico y de
muchas creencias todos celebramos
principalmente la Navidad que es hermosa
no parece muy emocionado
en Argentina la Navidad es en verano así
que es diferente
fuegos artificiales toda la noche
comemos empanadas suele haber asado
obviamente nos sentimos muy orgullosos
de ello y nos gusta divertirnos por las
personas en las calles lanzando fuegos
artificiales puedes ver los fuegos
artificiales
cortes de carne para asado
y como defecto hay matambre entraña
también hay chorizo pero eso es genérico
no finito igualmente es latina hasta el
final en la música nos conocen por el
tango pero la verdad lo que ibas a poner
en el fondo es cumbia
nuestros primos van a bailar y todos van
a tener la camisa de Messi siempre beso
sudando soccer o fútbol de fondo todos
plátanos también el fútbol es una locura
Leo le suene el Real todos vale dale
campeón dale campeón un mes y vamos a
hacer chocotorta flan gelatina de
unicornio volador
merengue salsa típico todo eso y luego
nos levantamos a las 1 pm del día
siguiente
la época de Navidad todos sabemos que
nos encanta la navidad hacemos tamales
un lugar llamado Venecia y tiene una
finca
fiestas tienen comida arroz con gandules
todo tipo de carne bebidas tenemos
coquito y te quedas despierto toda la
noche a ver si solo se toma café es una
de mis fiestas familiares favoritas ya
que se celebra como si fuera una fiesta
un buen trabajo representando a mi país
voy a agotar por Tomás porque creo que
otras personas lo harían Andrés me
hubiera gustado ver más sobre sus
tradiciones familiares Tomás
eligieran a mí sé que me equivoqué es
una cosa bastante tonta qué son los
cortes de carne y todo lo del asado soy
un tonto lo siento ya sabe porque está a
punto de ser eliminado
pero Aylen sabes de sobra hay cosas que
alguien que no es de Argentina no habría
dicho no sé siento que en cuanto ella y
yo empezamos a hablar conectamos se
notaba
sé que lo puedes cobras y leño pero soy
brasileño estoy hablando portugués
que hables portugués no te convierte en
brasileño seguiré votando por Tomás
Andrés
el mayor error y concepto erróneo de ser
latino que tengo es el idioma y el
acento vivían los Estados Unidos
ilegalmente por un tiempo y perdí un
poco del español y de hecho conocía
muchos latinos que no hablaban español
muchos dicen no hablas español no eres
latino y no es así también como hablo
inglés fluido los chicos esperan que
tenga un acento latino sexy y yo digo no
hablo inglés con fluidez pero eso no me
hace menos latinas así
vivieron en Argentina durante 30 años y
yo no sé allí vivió allí durante 15 años
incluso allí las personas me decían sus
una chinita lo que significa una chica
asiática y no debía estar ahí incluso
aquí en los Estados Unidos cuando hablen
español me dicen porque hablas en
español quién te dejo hablar en español
y yo digo disculpa creo que es un gran
error que solo porque parezcas asiática
porque no te parezcas a la persona
estándar que viene de América Latina no
puedo hacer y no Latina latín es y que
siempre tengas que hablar en español
pero en realidad no creo que lo que
importa es la cultura la música lo que
compartes con los demás sobre todo los
dominicanos es el hecho de que ninguno
de ellos quiere reconocer que tiene una
ascendencia africana cualquier
dominicano que tiene algo negro en ellos
y responden no no son negros no son
negros tu tono de piel tu pelo todo
tienes ascendencia africana en ti tienes
que reconocerlo el color es muy el
racismo en la comunidad de Latina es
enorme es un problema yo no crecí
hablando español no fue hasta la
primaria que tome clases de español
siempre lo conocí pasivamente pero nunca
tuve la oportunidad de aprenderlo a
veces te sientes que no eres lo
suficientemente latines hola tina por
qué no hablas español con fluidez lo más
importante es que no hay un modelo único
de lo que significa ser Latina mientras
se compartan valores y comunidades es lo
que importa tengo algo muy divertido que
preguntar vacunas tienen alguna busca de
nacimiento
porque estoy celoso de que todos tienen
esas martitas ni siquiera puedo decir
mira yo también la tengo verla yo no la
tengo no tiene Estados Unidos y no la
tengo lo que pasa es que mientras sepas
de que estoy hablando sé qué
vacuna yo pienso que si no la tienes no
eres latino aunque no
pasa nada es como las pequeñas cosas que
tienen un gran impacto
creo que voy a votar por tu masa solo
porque creo que los demás lo van a hacer
es mejor prevenir que lamentar esta vez
Tomás Tomás y lo siento mucho
disculpa quedó afuera
un pulgar hacia arriba si quieren ir a
la cuarta ronda o un pulgar hacia abajo
si creen que encontraron al topo y
quieren terminar con una partida ahora
la mayoría ha votado y vamos a terminar
el juego ahora
decir algo rápido escuchen si alguno de
ustedes sigue siendo el topo vamos a
tener serios problemas lo juro por todo
si el color se vuelve verde todos
ustedes ganan si es rojo el topo sigue
en el juego y perdieron estoy nerviosa
en 3 2 1
discúlpanos con tu madre lo
siento mucho
el juego termino y los latinos ganaron
eso significa que los ganadores
recibirán un premio en efectivo y
también vamos a regalarles la
experiencia a 5º en la que podrán elegir
sus básicos favoritos de nuestra nueva
marca de ropa
que el topo levante la mano en
[Música]
mi nombre en el juego era Mikel rosa
pero te echas Michael Rose no soy latino
como adivinaron estudia en el extranjero
durante un semestre Bibi con chicos
mexicanos después a Andrés lo siento
mucho hermano preocupes
por eso pensé que lo había estropeado
porque tenía que probarme y ni siquiera
habla español
me alegro por ellos espero que no haya
habido mucho revuelo después de eso
cuando estaban encogiendo otros latinos
aunque Miguel no sea latino tiene un
espíritu latino ser latino está aquí en
nuestras mentes y en el corazón
Jubilee vive intensamente